montagvormittag bei der dritten
jägerbrigade im niederösterreichischen
mautern
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
trifft zu einem besuch nach
einer einweisung besichtigt die
ministerin die ausrüstung der dritten
jägerbrigade
die sensoren praktischen jedoch
irgendwelche für informationsgewinn und
dementsprechend verantwortung ziehen
können
danach zeigen die soldatinnen und
soldaten ihren einsatz bei einer
dynamischen vorführung
der beeindruckt nicht nur die
theoretische einweisung sondern auch die
darstellung der fähigkeiten und der
dritte garde die sonst ja niemand hat
das darf man nicht vergessen
insbesondere die vorführung in einem
urbanen umfeld in einer ganz besonders
herausfordernden situation immer
verbunden mit der hoffnung dass diese
szenarien nicht eintreten aber wir haben
gesehen wie viele fähigkeiten
hier verfügt wird und unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten haben das band welt gezeigt
werden